okay here we are you ready yes okay
ladies and gentlemen welcome to you your
favorite podcast you know the name okay
this is the second mic and I always
offer this thing it might to the guest
get on the singing might just know I
actually knew you weren't gonna sing so
we're not even gonna continue that part
of the podcast I'll tell you this I was
shocked like I did not expect that
that's how I start to market you know I
just want you know that's my theme song
people know they love the woo-woos I
listen I enjoyed it I was just surprised
and this funny cuz you asked me ahead of
time is there anything I should know and
I was like no no I remember everything's
good that's not something I should know
but I was delighted like when you go
back and watch this you will see me you
will see me enjoying myself but I wonder
if you like give me a little some people
wrap some people do a lot of crazy
things people you wouldn't even think do
some stuff but anyways welcome to the
podcast this is the very funny talented
new friend I'd like to consider mr.
Anthony Jeselnik okay you're here I love
that we've known each other for like for
like five or six years and I'm a new
friend well you know what it is is like
I always say like working when you work
in comedy it's like working at a super
Walmart and let's say you're in produce
and I'm in a tire section so we see each
other in the break room and we're like
oh hey man what's going on but when it
comes to like life events yeah I don't
know anything about you yeah you don't
call me when you're like I guess what
I'm doing like yeah or like this
happened to me or like I'm like huh
because it takes like what do you think
it takes for like comics to transition
from like just being colleagues to like
where it's like oh I'm genuinely I would
call you to be like you know do my mom
died or something like that honestly
all it takes and I have very strong
feelings about this you had
- we'd have to be in a bad situation
together we were like this show is the
worst show and we're stuck in this green
room for like we don't want to be doing
this we're both gonna eat it yeah and
we're gonna just didn't sure like you
have to it's like trial by fire yes like
once you've been in a weird situation
with someone otherwise it's like just
two people co-workers like you said yes
what it is it's not a bad thing
no like I've talked about this before
where I've been like you know people go
is that guy your friend and then I
thought someone's my friend and then I
found out they got married and I found I
think I made from the other comics we're
like all his wedding was beautiful and
that's the moment I go just mother
[ __ ] isn't my friend
yeah cuz I wasn't even a [ __ ] yeah I
always say uh if they're like are you
friends with this person I go I know I'm
enough to say hello yeah yeah you know I
could beg hey what's up man but I don't
like it but I can't tell you anything
about them I don't know your life I
don't know your siblings you know what
exactly you start to really think about
like but it's weird because you have to
use terminology like friend you used to
when you use that terminology as so you
have to unpack it you know it means so
much and then you go well wow I'm not I
don't know
and I give something I like if the
police came to the comedy store and they
were like do you know something was
happening so heavily just like it was
seen it I'd be like whoa I don't even
know this [ __ ] enemy yeah yeah
it's like if you wouldn't immediately
live for somebody then that's not
necessarily your friend yes I don't know
this is a weird business like this I
remember the first time I met you was
like you just at the store and it took
you a minute to like loosen up around
the comics I felt like you're not
impression like what is I think that's
fair I just did I really hated the
Comedy Store when I first started I
didn't like the vibe why because it was
like that I was I was very into putting
the work in yeah and it's in the Comedy
Store at that time and this is you know
you know 15 17 years ago it was like
come hang out like that's how you got
into the stories you hung out and didn't
like the people hanging out yeah yeah I
was like I'm gonna go home and write and
I'll do I'd rather do open mics then
like then hang out here it's not that
important to me and not until you know
Tommy left and they brought a new
management
then when I come come hang out and then
I was like what am I getting into yeah
and then I started to really enjoy
myself and now like it's one of the only
places I perform in the city well the
thing about hanging out which I which I
can understand someone like yourself
coming there is like I'll hang out if
I'm hanging out with people that's like
you want to feel like we're in the same
place or I don't want to use the board
level but like it's one thing to be
hanging out in the hallway but people
that have been doing comedy for 10 years
and they're trying to get into this
historic place but when you're hanging
out with people who like they just got
here six months ago and everybody's
hanging out you kind of like what's
going on here what is this process you
know and it's not about level as much I
want to use that word but I understand
what you mean but it's but there are
people at different levels who are like
relaxed you know what I mean it's like
we don't to be in the same level but you
can't be looking at me like I'm your
meal ticket either you know what I mean
that's when I'm like there are people
who are thirsty at the Comedy Store
we're always trying to get like come do
my belly room show and I'm like nah man
I don't do the belly like I don't want
to do that
they're like stop asking me for things
if you want to hang out and have a beer
and talk about the game I'm happy to do
that and I eventually kind of you know
found my crew I guess at the store
people that I'm comfortable with and
cool with and they're employees that I
consider a dear friends I don't know
dude you actually we're like I think
we're the same this way I did get the
point where you've been talking to
somebody for so long say over a period
of time that it is now uncomfortable for
me to go hey what's your name
unacceptable
yeah deep I want to say 70% of the
people at the Comedy Store
I don't know [ __ ] I'm talking to and
I've been there way longer than you
mm-hmm it's just it's just one of those
things I I caught I call walk out to get
my gun I'll go who's Johnny car Johnny
and now they know what I mean it's like
whoever I don't know anyone like once
doc left doc was like the ones don't
miss ya you know and like Adam like
someone's like like who should I talk to
and they're like I'll go talk to uh go
talk to Jamie and I'm like I don't know
somebody's name that like I have like
serious conversations with I come stand
there and we talk about
or something like that and I'm like you
know and it's like when I started
bringing my girlfriend I had this trick
where I'd be like I'm gonna introduce
you I know I know I tell her you
introduce yourself I want you to go
hi I'm Rachel so then they'll go oh I'm
and I go yeah oh that's I mean oldest
trick in the book I don't know but like
naughty and even like on top of names
there are numbers in my phone that I
don't know who's texting me and we had
conversations like back and forth that
I'm like who a name is a manager is this
egg's because it'll be like someone was
tepid they would text me for spots and I
thought it was Adam like the head yeah
right and I think I'm talking to Adam
the whole time yeah and then like a year
later they're like can I open for you in
Denver and I'm like the [ __ ] is this
like that's the world I talking to yeah
you got oh no see that's the I hate do
you get that a lot do you get like
younger comics is going like hey man I
just I just want to put my name in the
Hat for her you know I get a lot of uh
like no comics but employees be like I'd
love to open for you sometime and I'm
like that's not how it works
you know what I mean I ask you I'm not
like looking for people and also like
I'm not always on the road you know I
have my like my different people but
they're like I I should open for you and
I'm like I've never seen you perform
yeah like I have no idea what you're
good or not I don't know beyond that I
don't know you
mmm-hmm like what you so I'm just some
stranger that we're gonna be like
traveling or whatever it's gonna be
I don't know you like that you don't
think I have a list of people that like
I've known for a little while who I'm
like the same not even mentoring but
like just who I've known for a little
while I know those people you won't let
me ask you this do you find yourself
because of your personality I'm not
saying you have a standoffish
personality cuz I get you more now sure
you know I mean oh yeah
just from you you've like you open the
door a little bit now you know what I
mean but do you get frustrated that
people cuz I get frustrated by this put
you in a situation where now you gotta
be an [ __ ] I what like I went through
a period where it was uncomfortable you
know like I start to get some fame and
people start treating you differently I
didn't really know how to handle it you
you always want to be nice like you like
you go to do a talk show and then you're
like nervous about the talk show you're
ready dude like you're thinking about
your set and then some intern walks in
it's like can you do a quick video for
this I'm like okay and then you're like
out of your headspace that I hated that
but I it's important to be nice you know
but with my persona now I figured out
like my favorite saying is of course I'm
not going to do that cuz then the person
laughs and then you get out of it
completely but like I've just learned
how to how to say no but I feel like
when people don't understand how
something works and then they hit you
with a question
it's just I'm at the Comedy Store you
get you might get somebody just like ask
you the question like hey can I can I
open for you and now you're put in this
position when you gotta be like you know
I don't I don't know you or you know and
then they want to go further if they say
like well why or what can I do that's
the moment where you gotta be like you
don't get it
see I don't have any patience for that
like I want to be nice but I do not
suffer fools I like that I like that
expression where like and I never ask
someone to open for them when I was
coming up like I would have loved you
know the gig but I just knew not to do
it so when people continually ask or you
like put them off politely and they keep
coming back to you and I'm thinking of
like one person at the store in
particular noticed like he's come back
that I'm just like like I don't feel bad
for you anymore because you're going
about this so poorly right right right
right I remember when I was first coming
up I asked a couple people because I
didn't know and then after that I
realized when I got to that position I
was like what was I doing so now I know
what these things get people I get this
to adjust or sometimes one of those door
guys or one of those people will be like
hey can you watch my set you know I'm
gonna go up and what you can you watch
my set and I'm like damn but if I in my
mind I'm thinking if I watch your set
and I don't like you I won't be talking
to you for a long time I like is hard I
don't know what it is but for me if I
don't think these people that are like
high level that I don't necessarily find
and find funny but I consider them
entertaining and I can respect their
business savvy right I call it who gives
a [ __ ] test it's like you're killing
your doing your job
like I don't mind finally that you met
you don't ruin the crowd right right
right but people don't leave thinking
about like who's that guy you were a man
right so there's people like that right
you know whatever you might even think
of that of me now you gotta listen I
wouldn't be here if I thought that of
you laughter that's true and I've told
you and I'd like a guy who runs around
like telling ya bits but you're Jason
Voorhees the missile Ron should be my
brother and laughing about it all the
time I love to know that you know but
but this is what I'm saying though it's
like if you if you'd find someone say
completely not funny at all it's hard to
even be around them it's hard to be
around somebody that you just go that
you can't even respect their business
you just like somebody that's like
you're not I just I can't I can't be
around this so that it's hard to be
friends with people because people think
that when comics hang out all we do is
talk about his comedy and it's so not
true
no you know what I mean maybe right
after I set you might be like what did
you think of this or you know what I
don't do that you made me take tags you
don't do callbacks you don't know super
different style some of that can I give
you something I'm like no like there was
an employee I came offstage and then I
can I give you one note and I was like
of course not like of course you can't
yeah you know what I learned that you
know what it's hilarious then I knew
this a long time ago because a lot of
times I'll see somebody go onstage and I
am they're like I love tagging somebody
stuff I love because I am inserted what
they're saying and how they're saying it
I love that but I've learned a long time
ago to go the first question is do you
take and then you would be like now and
I go ok that's it we're done cuz
somebody might be like oh yeah woody
what do you got and even if they listen
to it they might be like yeah what time
I went up to Rogan and I in the kitchen
and I had a tag for him and he looked at
me and I knew he hated it because he
just shook my hand and walked out and
just the way he did it I appreciate it
you know he was like you know yeah
no man that's not a good one and he just
[ __ ] forget left but you know I just
don't want it in my head you don't I
mean like I just like I I like I'd come
up with it all myself and I'll figure it
out eventually I don't want the note
will just ruin my process it's not like
a disrespect thing I'm like oh like how
dare you give me a tag it's like that's
not how I work
yeah well I look at your comedy I don't
think it would work like that anyway
because you're very meticulous I would
consider you a wordsmith just because of
they had to be set a certain way so you
can get to where you're trying to get to
because if not one little thing off it
could come across as like oh my god I
guys tear a hole like a terrible person
I mean you know so I like how you
construct that so I could totally see
how you know what when did that start
for you when did it become a thing where
you were like oh I want to do comedy
this way and be so meticulous about it
cuz I can tell you put a lot of work in
mm-hmm what a great question when I
first started I was 23 years old and
imagine like me at 23 going on stage and
like I took a class and they were like
talking with me did I talk about your
life because that's what you can tell
everyone in the class no one's gonna be
like hey write really smart jokes you
know I mean I don't no one does that and
I loved Stephen right you know I love
Mitch Hedberg I love Jack Handey but I
thought those guys were geniuses I can't
do that but I was also like a boring 23
year old like who the hell wants to hear
what I have to say about my life right
that I hated that I had a couple stories
and I was always telling and I was like
this is nothing fun and then I saw BJ
Novak had an open mic and he was just
doing one-liners like smart inert like
like no connection jokes that I was like
oh you can do that and that looks like
fun that I could only get up you know
five minutes a night but I could write
all day long but I'm gonna outright
people you know I'm just gonna write
more than everyone else and if I write a
hundred jokes one of them has to be
great you know and so I just it would
became a volume game no one use I really
enjoyed that when you say you write all
day you seriously sit like you have a
schedule where you go I'm gonna write
from 10:00 to 1:00 or Wanda oh not not
anymore not anymore or you just have
your it speak like in the B dressing
yourself more well I I know my voice now
and I know what I can and can't talk
about and it doesn't help me to write
ten jokes as opposed to five you know
I've just gotten better at like I work
smarter almost yeah yeah and I've
covered I'm working on my fifth hour
right now and I've covered some of the
basics thank you
there's so I've covered so many topics
that I didn't it I don't have the wide
open field I used to when I was looking
for my voice and finding that I could
write all day in the beginning when I
was an open mic or I would literally
spend hours like I think you in front of
the TV you're just like shutting down
thoughts they're not all great but I was
like get it out of my system
now uh a couple times a week I'll go and
Leo cinema sit on the couch with a
laptop and and try to write you know
four or five good jokes try them out
that night but by failing I'd stand up
like when I'm when you when you put out
in a new hour and I got to start from
scratch I really have to go up and bomb
I have to go up and bomb with new stuff
because and that makes me go home and
work more but if I kept doing old stuff
I would never work on new stuff right
right right right
like bombing I think is so important to
become a good becoming a good comedian
that I like that I still do it you know
I I almost I don't feel that way because
what you just said I think that it's the
work that you put in because I'm
recognizing like when you like a place
at the Comedy Store or comics in LA you
know they're there's so many like really
funny people but the thing that makes
you go from really funny person to like
that next year of being super successful
which I think that you're in is this
extra work that is put in you know
that's what I think I mean I think that
you say it's bombing but like I think
that you're just comfortable in yourself
with these certain jokes but that work
you put in to bring that onstage a lot
of people aren't doing that they're just
not and I know because I don't always do
it sure it's a thing about like a
professional basketball player who just
plays basketball versus the guy who goes
to the weight room you know what I mean
it's not as fun it's not why you did it
but you're putting in that extra work
that people don't see you know that I
think makes makes a difference honestly
I think my secret to success was ripping
off a writer and not another comedian
when I first started do you know what I
mean like everyone retakes someone that
they like that they love us on or
whatever and they do that and then
hopefully after a year you figure out
your own thing I picked Jack Handey as
opposed to Steven right you know and
people will still compare me to those
guys but it wasn't as obvious like you
knew the guy who was doing Hedberg you
know you knew that person you're like
good luck
that but by choosing a writer it was
like most people just didn't know so I
got it's more successful more quickly
yeah well I mean I think that it is I
think it is good I always like seeing
the comics that you can see the riders
the people that put the extra work in
because they always get the little piece
of paper with them you know like you're
just one of those guys I go oh I've seen
that so the guy had bought myself this
little notebook and I was like oh I get
it
even because something about the process
of writing something down you instantly
start seeing it differently and then
that's where the stuff comes that's
where the extra like as you're just
you're tagging yourself mm-hmm
you know because you you obviously don't
remember everything that happens on
stage and there's so many variables to
comedy that's what I love going to the
comedy store because it's like you never
know it's like going up after you is
different from going up after Chris
D'Elia oh yeah you know what I mean
completely you know so it's like and
then you're like you were in the back
just like I'm gonna deal with this [ __ ]
right now cuz it's a transference of
energy I I'm never like I don't have
that attitude but I know like if it's if
I'm gonna show like if we're doing the
main room and you and I are off on the
same land yeah yeah yeah we don't always
like you I bring you ever you bring me
yeah I don't know why Adam does that
yeah I don't know what his like yeah why
why I've gotta be in that like I'm never
first you know I mean it's like you're
going in this thing but if it's like a
show where it's where like the biggest
guy and then the biggest name is D'Elia
yeah I'm like let's go eat it you know I
mean like it's just like a bunch of
girls who are mad at me whereas if
Brogan's on the line up I'm like okay
yes gonna be Dubrow yeah exactly
different vibe like I used to open for I
open for two different people and then
for them for the most part when I first
started when I got to that opener and a
point and it was a Brian Posehn and Doug
Benson oh and Brian Posehn I would
destroy like his fans loved me but Doug
Benson I would walk people who wouldn't
even wait to see Doug they bought
tickets for Doug and they hated me so
much they would leave that it was just
like I've never got one of those comics
who's like any cup if you're a good
comic you can kill wherever it's like no
you cannot like I opened for TIG once
like it this is like a year ago she was
just like come to my Largo show and I
was like sure and I showed up and it
takes a good friend
mine and I'm like how much time like
because normally like I did largo last
night and it's like people do in 10
minutes and then i go up and do my thing
at the end and it takes like 2 25 30 and
I'm like TIG I'm gonna eat it so hard
and she's like now it'll be finally be
great and I bombed it was a sold-out
show I bombed so hard like the crowd
despised me bombed so hard that then she
bombed yeah where I her own show cuz
they were just like didn't know what was
going on why do you think that is I
think I'm just
I always saying if you didn't if you
don't want to see me you don't want to
see me you know if you're not like
buying tickets to see it and
occasionally people are like discover me
and are surprised but for the most part
like I'm tickets to a horror movie you
know I mean a lot of people go to comedy
shows expecting you know comedy and they
want like at the romantic comedy it's
like no I'm a different kind of thing
somebody's head gets slit you know yeah
it chopped off when you're you're their
head getting chopped off in the opening
scene you're like oh my god exactly
people just don't understand and they
think comedy like people will be like
are you really like that and I'm like
you can't be that stupid like you can't
be that stupid to think and then I like
someone there was a comic who's like are
you are you a psychopath and I know like
what and why would you ever ask me that
but no I'm not I have a therapist and
I've asked her and she's like no you're
not you're cool laugh but like and then
I quote the jokes you come up with
though you have to admit that like
there's something in there and I'm like
are you mad at Stephen King yeah I mean
like exact like to know it only in
comedy do they really think that you you
there must be something in there and
it's like no no this is just what I'm
interested in writing by the way two
things one that's just a testament to
how well you're doing your thing true
okay because cuz there was a time that I
was like I don't know this dude's kind
of a dick you know I mean yeah you know
like because and it was part of it I
realizes because of the onstage persona
mm-hmm and then offstage
you're just unapproachable you don't
mean at first I see one you seem
unapproachable but it's just the way you
have like it's almost like resting
[ __ ] you know I mean like you have
a way of just being like I
won't you come in because like right now
you just smile and I go oh what a nice
guy like you can if you had a Santa
outfit on you'd be perfect
yes you don't mean you got to view the
other eyes I'd be like but so you
probably got sick of people being like
oh hey that so you have a way of like
it's like a okay no no it's so there was
a part of me when I first started seeing
you there where I was like I don't know
what does help just do but then it was
just one day where you were just like
hey hey and you were just like hey what
you know and I was like oh I was like
this dude's fine but I'm telling you
it's just a testament to what you're
doing on stage sure but I think the
resting [ __ ] thing carries a lot of
weight like I I was in the Starbucks and
some I was in line and someone turns
around to excuse me oh and I was like
and I was like what can I help you and
she say oh would you just hold my spot
in line I was like of course yeah and
she's like okay but whatever what my
face was was like you know you know how
like people have a petition or survey
outside the store and they're the one
that they don't even yeah I bother with
you
yeah there's people who are like would
you do a moment for Greenpeace like
right they let me walk right behind but
I but I enjoy that like yeah I have a
why I feel like being unapproachable is
a good thing sometimes at a place like
salic in the comedy world and like
anywhere you are where there's like a
lot of hungry thirsty comics mm-hmm
there's a certain thing sometimes you
just got to be like you know cuz they'll
come take all your time but I might seem
unapproachable but I've never like blown
someone off like it's a lot of its body
language yeah you know like it's like if
someone comes up and starts talking to
me I'll talk to whoever but like I might
be turning my shoulder a little bit you
know a man like I'm letting them get one
without the convo were you ready to go I
don't know it's just a weird thing now
you know I was thinking about this
you're you talked about your style of
comedy and I appreciate it I like you
know and it is I'm not gonna say the
whole thing is dark but you do you use
dark topics to bring you know it's like
a rollercoaster ride but do you find
like in the last four years how
sensitive the culture can be has I can
tell it has it has an effect you you
haven't stopped doing it but was it did
you have a thought process
not at all was there like oh man this is
gonna be [ __ ] up for me
no it really like I kind of it just I
don't think of it in that way you know
I'm just doing what I do and I've
continued to be successful with yeah for
sure I might not make as much money as
some other people but I still make yeah
you know I'm yeah I'm not gonna cry into
my pile of money because PC culture is
doing whatever but I've kind of been
like I don't know if I could if I was
starting now if I could do what I do
that's interesting you know
grandfathered in I've been doing 18
years so it's like people know I'm
almost a guilty pleasure now I'm the one
guy who still gets to do it so I went
and I really enjoy that position of
privilege right now in comedy and I
think it'll I think it's only gonna get
worse but if I was starting now no way
yeah no way would I be able to do it it
would be hard yeah I always I always
think like with people with some of the
guys that are like successful now who've
been doing to the 25 years just the way
they do comedy even with the state of
like the internet and social media it's
like would they be able to do what
they've done now we're just being funny
you know I mean that and like the fact
that you can put out a special every
year if you want to you know someone
will do it people they put it up online
if they want to do it yeah and before
that wasn't the case he just worked on
your act and now people are trying to
turn it over as quickly as they can to
make the most money yeah I mean I I put
more time I mean because I do one like
almost one-liners it takes me a long
time when I see people putting out
specials every like two years I just I
can't believe it and when they're great
it's really impressive but a lot of them
are it's just kind of an exact that's
all it is I hate the word content like
that's what it is it's like I'm an
artist you know I mean like I remember
like John capper illah one day was like
oh it's not art man he's like and I
don't feel bad like I would say this to
his face and I don't know him at all but
he was just like man I'm like it it's
not art it's just I just go up there and
I do my thing it's it's just comedy it's
just like I'm just go up and I'm talking
I'm like for you yeah you know what I
mean like I consider myself an artist
do I sound pretentious when I say that
yes is it pretentious of course does it
motivate me and help me to do what I do
yes 100% yeah but anybody can consider
what they do
as art I mean yeah there's like I feel
what you're saying cuz then it becomes
like you feel like well this is a lack
of respect for because it's called an
art form but I just think because of
what the world is right now with social
media and YouTube and all this and these
youtube stars who are making so much
money off you know putting out content
for their people I mean I think the
comics to catch up we can't call them
special anymore they're not special it
was special because it was only like for
a year in the whole business mm-hmm so
they would be like oh that's special now
it's like you know like everybody you
got to do it just to keep up with the
Joneses yeah you know and I just I don't
know like I really enjoyed Chappelle's
last special but like he put out five
specials in two years and my own nothing
on him I love him but what I didn't what
I don't appreciate about it is he's so
big now that like he if he talks about a
subject because he's put out five
specials now it's like the people go
whoa oh ship hell did that even if
you're just using a word mm-hmm so like
if you took like he's made transgender
his Jim Gaffigan is hotpokket a little
bit but I mean but I find it to be an
opportune like I've got a transgender
joke I was very proud of it but I was
like this is an opportunity if you can
find the right way it's like you can't
talk about this it's like you can you
just have to find the right way to do it
that I'm like I'm obsessed with that
like that's how you're gonna have to be
smart about it now that like yeah I
agree with that that that but if he but
if you're taking his tact about it right
then it's like he's done that yeah
that's good you know what what you're
saying right now is like it's just what
you what you do we just talked about
about how you've made it an art form and
you really are meticulous and you take
the time to do that that's what that's
what the me to movement that's what all
the sensitivity that's what all this has
made us do I think it's it's separating
the great comics from the pack
because you really have to be thoughtful
there's a good word to use about what
you're talking about making it your own
and I appreciate that too I feel like I
still want to be misogynistic sometimes
I mean women are half the population
they're hilarious mm-hmm you know me the
things they do and say are hilarious
sometimes and I still want to be able to
talk about it so now I realize I have to
talk about it in a way that they laugh
too
at themselves as opposed to them just
being like I'm uncomfortable or you know
what you don't mean it's one of the
reasons that I went dark is that I got
accused of misogyny early on like my
first album had a lot of like my
girlfriend jokes you know like yeah and
it was like trashing my girlfriend and I
mean all made up but I was like and
you'd hear people laughing different you
do a joke about race and you hear people
laughing differently that I was like if
I talk about death everyone's in the
same boat right you know that you can I
do I still have jokes that that could be
considered misogynistic yes
do I have jokes that could be considered
racial of course but darkness every like
everyone's gonna die it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter if you're like if
you're if you're a guy whatever but I
try to hit everybody you know the ones
if someone comes up and complains about
one of my jokes I'm like but you like
the rest of them if you don't I mean
like you like it's on you if you get mad
I love how they ignore the other 45
minutes of laughter mm-hmm but they just
go you know that one thing you said I
didn't never you know but you know I
stopped do you even look at comments and
things like that do you even like are
you online like did this is it has there
ever been like a response to a tweet
where you've been like this [ __ ]
and you want it to like dive in I like
all but I call it like just dunking on
someone if I could my tweets like if
someone says some comments made
something but like and I can do it in
four words you don't I mean just trash
and I'll do it but I would never like
I'm never actually having conversation
it's like I'm gonna use this as a joke
you know this is like a setup to a joke
I used to never look at anything we're
know like when you're first starting out
you look at the YouTube comments because
you're like anyone commenting on my work
is like you're just you can't believe
you get the attention at all yeah but
then they all start to become the same
whether they're good or they're bad
they're the same and I used to like not
look at Twitter very often occasionally
you'd look at something like after so
are you putting something out if I tweet
I look at comments on that
then I started getting like threats
where I gotten to remember that the girl
Deena Hashem who made a joke about that
rapper xxx oh yeah yeah yeah and so I
was like and I'm talking to her and
she's like a mess because these people
are coming out or so hard on Twitter
that I'm it wrote of tweets basically
like about the fans like this is like
not cool and I made a joke and those
[ __ ] were out of their minds
and they're like googling my family like
right so the tweets are like this is
these are the names of your siblings
that I'm like now I'm looking at [ __ ]
just to be like I've got a report this
guy was right I got to call my brother
and tell him to like make his phone
number private so I look at things now
because of just the net like the
negativity and the toxicity is so crazy
but you have to protect yourself like
that I don't have someone looking over
my social meeting I'm really only on
Twitter right but I do look at those now
just because people have I've had to
report people really damn I mean I asked
Rogen about it because he's so big on
the so I said when did you stop looking
at comments he was like I don't look at
him anymore at all
and he said I don't look at the negative
ones and I don't look at the positive
ones because they can have the same
negative effect on your head and I was
like oh I totally get that but when you
first start doing a part this is a new
podcast for me so I'm on the comments
looking you know then I find myself
sometimes somebody says something and
I'll be like you know what [ __ ] off my
page and don't you ever come back you
know well I don't know about you but I I
would never leave a negative comment
like it
I don't leave comments period but to be
like to leave a negative one it's like
go find something you like I especially
when you have so many - I feel like that
that what the airline say you thank you
for flying United you have so many
choices we appreciate this one I'm like
why are you here if you think I'm trash
you don't like me
yeah why are you going out of your way
to find my video a lot of times watch it
mm-hmm watch the whole video because
they're commenting on parts of it that
they're like an S anonymous there's a
God had made a whole video after all I
did a Showtime special okay and this guy
made a whole youtube video about why he
didn't like it
yeah and it hit me up talking about hey
man I really wish you would do a
response video so we could have a have a
dialogue I thought to myself are you out
of your [ __ ] mind
that's amazing he wanted to meet it he
wanted me to have a lifelong hump amount
the fact that I'm even talking about
right now in census me there was a guy I
did Marc Maron's podcast years ago and
we talked we were talking about using
the word [ __ ] you know like and he
was like you've got a great joke they
use that word he's like I had one back
in the day that I used to do and we're
laughing about it and then some guy like
writes this article blaming jokes about
[ __ ] people for this one [ __ ]
kid who got killed by his classmates and
like beaten up and killed and I was like
these two are not related at all not
even a little and I wrote him back and I
was like listen like I completely
disagree with what you're saying here
but if you want to talk about it like
I'll talk about with you and this is a
long time ago I would never engage like
that now and the guy just wrote back
Anthony read my article like they didn't
want they didn't care about the response
it was just like they want the attention
from you that's you that I'm like I'm
never gonna give that to you it's it's a
hard thing man it's I know you know and
it's like what I find is you probably
experienced this too so people take
things personal to them if it's
something in their life you know like if
you talk about like one day I was I have
I have a joke about guns okay and I was
talking about this is I was using the
example of this kid in Santa Barbara
there was a shooting in Santa Barbara
and he killed all these women that
didn't like him you know so I'm just
talking about mental health and stuff
and I'm just saying like guys you know
this is gonna be a shock to you but I
too have been rejected by women you know
I've never thought I need to kill these
[ __ ] but anyway I'm talking about
what happened and I think I'm being
thoughtful but there just happened to be
a girl in the crowd who actually went to
that school and knew people that got
killed you know so that moment for her
it wasn't gonna be funny for her at all
and that just happens with all you
wouldn't I have a transgender joke and
it's like there's somebody whose sister
or brother
it's going through some [ __ ] and they're
not gonna take it like that so it's like
it's a delicate balance to like that's
why we don't look at the comments yeah
but it like you know we perform for
crowds yeah yeah I mean yeah you're
gonna get some people who aren't in art
into it and it's like that's fine but
why you coming to me you know yeah yeah
I don't need to hear about like if
you're not laughing okay like I get it
if someone's like I don't like your
comedy I don't ask why like I got a
pretty good idea why it doesn't matter
it's still my comedy like the things
people hate me for
they're people who love me for that same
thing so why why care about the thing
for me though I don't mind if somebody
says that to me I want people to say
like I don't find you funny I'm like
okay cool I get that but what I can't
stand is like you're not funny and
you're fat
was that part necessary whenever anyone
says you're not funny
what they're saying is you're not funny
to me but they leave the to me off
because that makes him sound like a
[ __ ] idiot right you know you're not
funny to me
like what do you enjoy also the
arguments done look if all you get
you've said the reason and you've given
the explanation so there's no place for
us to go yeah but I I get been bitten
most negative comment I get like all the
time it's like I could predict his joy
like I see every joke coming no you do
not I tried so many jokes that if people
see them coming they don't work you know
what I mean right so like if I'm touring
and I've like honed it down to this set
you cannot see them coming and a lot of
people now because of the content thing
the watch your special with the
subtitles on and that ruins [ __ ]
jokes like yeah I bet if you watch it
with you your jokes
yeah the timing is very important I did
this a Netflix special and they show me
the trailer they do this trailer and
then like they make cuts in they show
whole joke with him they make cuts to
make it shorter and quicker and I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing like do you
think I'm like yeah like if you do you
think you're helping me like you're
making the joke better like I tell the
joke that's slowly for a reason yeah I
pause there for a reason I snap my
fingers for a reason and you're taking
it out
just to get the words out and that ruins
it yeah I don't know who these people
are that do these kinds of things you
know I look after I did a half-hour on
Comedy Central um the half hours were
notorious dude the first time I used to
look at the half hours and I would be
like this is terrible
and what I did it I finally understood I
was like oh cuz they make people that
you would consider that guys are really
funny
he's funny at the Comedy Store he's
funny wherever and then you see the half
hour you're like what did they do and I
get it cuz one it's just one taping
mm-hmm you know whatever the environment
is it is what it is and then they have
somebody they like editing that you're
like what are you adding for that
they'll I mean like I'd be telling a
long story with a huge punch line at the
end and they'll hear one laugh and like
the beginning and then cut there yeah
you know what I mean
people there's a fit they're famous
examples of people who have like they
end on a callback you and they'll cut
the joke they're calling back - and
leave that like it I mean it's and then
then they pair you with someone oh and
you don't know like I remember Doug I
did my half hour and Doug Benson was
doing his like second half hour and he
was like man when I did my first one
like years ago I was paired with like
Cory K Haney after she's done Last Comic
Standing the flick the first season and
it was all her fans and suck he's like
let's ask to be together
so we can do it like who do together and
I went first and as I'm walking offstage
and Doug's walking on I realize he's my
[ __ ] cortico Haney you know what I
mean like it was I was a different set
because they were all waiting for Doug
like I'm getting heckled and then like
in the edit and now I got put out an
album and they're like oh you can see
the uncut version of his half hour and
I'm like I don't want that out there
yeah yeah like half of it's me stick
like yelling at a camera guy who left
his mic on you know like I can hear
people I'm like waiting for the audience
to quiet down like this I don't want
this out there
this is terrible I did I did my half
hour with low rel in Boston did you go
first a second I went first okay but I
thought they set him up for failure you
know because one we're doing it in
Boston okay and like we're I guess the
ethnic group of that particular year of
doing the specials and so you know I'm
like the people that were the new me at
the time for Comedy Central were like
Bros you know workaholics fans you know
they're just like you know so I remember
even though my I just went off to
cuffing me like weird a whole experience
and always like ah you know I mean he
that's not his crowd they were never
even the same kind of people they told
me they played that half-hour one time
and then that was it really
yeah and I was just like damn that they
it's like they don't take any thought
into like how can we make this great
like don't you want this to be great I
just I don't get it is it just for them
content you know what I mean it kind of
it I mean especially when the half-hours
like it's almost like MTV stopped
playing music video yeah people are like
why and if they were like listen like I
understand what you're saying but if we
show a rerun of the real world it does
way better than music videos they're
like comedy central's like we get it we
should be doing more stand-up but if we
show stand-up it gets less it gets lower
ratings than anything else we put on
literally that's why a special now is
like on a midnight on Sunday you're like
what what are you watching
why are you doing this and it's like
well that's just the best we can do then
they throw it on their app who like
who's on that app like no one the
whenever anyone talks about apps
yeah when if you talk about the Comedy
Central app you say app in a different
way yeah because of the way they've like
made everyone you know I I just I just
don't get it I you know it's like you're
gonna have you they're supposed to be
the safeguards of comedy that's what I
always used to think coming up because
it was like Comedy Central mm-hmm this
is where comedy is centralized they said
on Family Guy one time but it's like
like you say MTV doesn't play music The
Learning Channel you don't learn [ __ ]
anymore
mm-hmm and now Comedy Central does no
[ __ ] [ __ ] man the History Channel is
about like Ice Road Truckers and yeah
that's what that's what plays on TV
Weather Channel has like reality shows
the one you can't even look at the
Weather Channel and get like you know I
didn't know what's the weather in
Wisconsin they're like well after you
know
they get the trucker [ __ ] on that thing
- like what is happening but that's why
I love them
I love having like your own YouTube
channel you kind of your own producer
your own thing you don't feel like
you're at that point where you can like
release a special wherever you want or
do you like to prestige if it being on
Netflix because that's where it's at
right now I don't want to deal with the
[ __ ] you know like they're cool man
like when comics like direct their own
special I'm like I don't [ __ ] do that
like I want nothing that like why would
you give it away I'm like because I
don't want to have to do the work like
at you like this whole set up that
you've done like I would never do this
like I just don't care like I don't have
an Emmy I think it's cool you do it yeah
but I was like I won't I'll do a podcast
I have a podcast on a Comedy Central
network and I was like I do it because I
couldn't do everything you just come in
yeah I come in the studio was there it's
all set up too and it's like I don't
have to deal with any of the other
things yeah a little thing though I get
you this is a nightmare
okay there's a full-time job stand-up
comedy ruins you for other art form
if you know what I mean did I people why
aren't you acting I'm like I don't want
to sit in a trailer like I'm used to I
show up you know I wrote a drink no I
mean I will if someone's like hey come
do this live I'm happy to auditioning no
anyway even when I do act like today of
them I got to do this like it's
something I have to do and stand up as a
get to do when I was coming up I always
felt like stand-up comedy was a means to
an end so you would get you would do
stand-up to transition into like being
on a sitcom or being in movies but right
now in the last five six years I feel
like this is this is like a new golden
age for stand-up were like the stand-up
is the end where like it's like a viable
like really lucrative business for
people right now and that must that must
be great for you it's nice I mean I
don't get to benefit as much as some
people do like there are people who the
Netflix special comes out and they
announced the tour the next day yeah you
know and I'm like I can't do that my
Netflix special comes out and I
announced the tour two years later oh
because I've got to like right and kind
of material yeah but the people who do
that I'm like that's so smart you're
making so much more money you're cashing
in on this cachet you have right now but
I just can't work like that and as far
as acting goes I mean I got into
stand-up because I wanted to be a writer
and someone was like if you do stand-up
people can instead of reading your jokes
will be able to see your jokes but by
the time I finally got the writing job I
was doing well enough at stand-up that I
was rather just do this why-why-why work
for someone else
but acting like I'm a much worse actor
now than I was like in college you know
I got to get a couple acting classes in
college and I really enjoyed it and I
was good at it but you know if you're
acting and you know this you've got to
be listening to and when you're doing
stand-up you're not listening to [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it's like you're just you're
the in charge that I just can't I can't
turn it off like I've gotten time too
much in stand-up mode that if we were
doing a scene together I'm not listening
to anything you say you know I mean I'm
like pretending I am you know what I
disagree with you man I disagree with
you you are listening could you listen
to the crowd the crowd your seat partner
then you pause for a reason because
you're listening for a certain thing
it's subtle it's nuanced but you very
much are performing that's why people
are so that's why people think that your
your stage persona is the same guy off
stage that's what people think that
because of your acting performance I
mean you're listening for a laugh and
again it's a performance but it's a
monologue you know I'm not like I'm not
going back and I don't do a lot of crowd
work and if I do if I'm doing crowd work
the other person's in trouble yeah yeah
it's not like let's have fun let's talk
let's have fun together you know oh
you're a big fan let's let's go like
those people who like want to laugh
extra hard to let you know they get it
like just as annoying as someone booing
you yeah I don't see you as like no dude
I used to get super angry that like if
somebody's heckling are ruining the show
in some kind of way that would get me
and then now I'm like in a mode of like
I need to destroy you and I'm but that I
realized in therapy that that's not
healthy if it's look at the if there's
someone's heckling at the Comedy Store
you know they're just there to see a
show and that like they take it they get
mad or they want to make it about them
then I'm like I don't feel bad at all
like I'll go at them but it's like I'm
on tour and someone pays a lot of money
to come see me and they're just it's
always there it's always drunk it's
always as someone who's
wasted and that's like they'll be in the
front row and they like they're like
yeah after jokes and [ __ ] we were just
like hey man hey I need you do
especially for your stuff yes this is a
symphony I need you to yeah the
community you can't do you can't make
this show about you yeah there's too
many people here that I've had to throw
people out just being like you're too
drunk now I I used to like you got to
give them some rope so the audience
isn't like oh this guy's being real
sensitive you gotta let them like know
they're being annoying but I used to
just I would just deal with it and now I
do not there's like a tally in your head
you're like strike one
mmm-hmm dude I did I went did some
shells with Dane you're right and it's a
[ __ ] theater gig and there was a
drunk couple heckling him and I thought
this is crazy
there's like 3,000 people here to see
this guy and you two these two [ __ ]
want to make a thing out of it yeah it
just boggles the boat it boggles my [ __ ]
I would never act that way in a million
years I always say the crowd or
somebody's messing around I always say
like pretend you're at cast or you know
you're at Hamilton or like you know cuz
you wouldn't be like oh yeah you
wouldn't you wouldn't do that
I had a girl get kicked out of a show
once I was at like stand-up live in New
York and this girl gets thrown out and
after I like she says she's like yelling
[ __ ] out of me and I'm like get out of
here and I always say like Mike code is
you know some people be like can we get
them a glass of water
oh that means get him out yeah yeah I'm
like my code is get the [ __ ] out like if
you hear me say that like you know and
they said the girl leaves and she starts
crying when they kick her out and she
goes and her excuse was he's saying
offensive things why can't I say
offensive things and it's like that's
not what this show was like but comedy
is the most disrespected art form and
everyone thinks they can do it that like
they just get too excited it's like if
you're watching John wick and you just
like start shadowboxing and right or
right you know elbowed a guy next to you
like yeah like I understand you're
pumped up I gotta be great though let me
be a funny sketch action to film because
that's how people think about it yeah I
know it's like yeah you're not I used to
when I was like younger I would tell
by the way the worst hecklers always
women like I don't understand what it is
but it's all wait like the worst
experiences I've ever had right I don't
know about you agree on a person it's
like always women and like I had it
remember I was in Texas I didn't tell
this chick I said look you need to stop
because you're pushing me and you will
be outside crying you know and she
wouldn't stop they sure enough you know
she believed in she's crying outside the
bouncers like me and that's when I feel
bad though oh I don't I don't feel bad
at all like moment I feel like I
shouldn't went that far I mean what I do
and I have to be very careful because
I'm so mean that my ass if I like if I'm
too mean like if I call someone I can't
like to do any it's kind of like oh like
it's like and I can't lose control what
I do is I put it on her boyfriend I mean
I'm like I'm like hey listen lady it's
your house in order on that I'm not mad
at you but whoever you're with right now
needs to handle this [ __ ] yeah and the
audience goes nuts and you never hear
another word cuz the guys like you
better shut of course I do honestly I
don't think it's like a female thing I
think it's a drunk thing oh I think it's
like it's like women can't don't handle
their alcohol is a very drunk woman is
gonna be more annoying than a very drunk
guy but I've had very drunk guys who
just think they're my number one fan
like ruined like ruin things just as
badly I think it's more alcohol than
either one but a drunk woman is you know
but I just
becae I just I don't I disagree I don't
think it has to do with like one in the
alcohol I think that I just personally
feel like the female ego is in the
female ego versus the male ego they're
so different about what makes them upset
and like how they deal with it you know
it's like guys like if there's guys in
the crowd and one guy's trying to be
like whatever if I go say something
about him you know what happens his all
his friends go oh you know and it's like
that embarrassment shuts that guy down
it's done
yeah you can't embarrass a woman will
not be embarrassed cuz she's like I'm
going to win this
threshold like I you I agree with you
now like you did you see the thing
recently there was a couple there's a
play about slavery that's in New York oh
yeah yeah and all the slaves yeah and
the this the playwright is doing a QA
and this white woman stands up and is
like this is racist against white people
and it's like what is going through your
mind that you think that you're supposed
to say this like that you're gonna get
up and like people be like this is wrong
what you're doing like you don't hear
all these other people laughing like
it's a win in Rome situation yeah you
know even if you're upset like just sit
there and be upset and then get up and
leave no but I just I always think like
this is what I'll you just say to them
up cuz I'll be like I get it like I'm up
here I'm an average-looking dude
everybody's paying attention to me and
here you are you know you're all dolled
up and no one cares mm-hmm so I
understand that this might be a thing
but what you don't understand is no dude
in this room right now is going oh
that's the one I want the one that won't
shut the [ __ ] up I've just had so many
experiences where it's like and what
they don't get is like the guy that
they're with like you say there's a guy
with them and he's just like this you
know that's like you know the guys never
defend them like like you know when
you're going off on a chick you're going
the guy's just sitting there like you
know why he's doing that because he
wants her to shut the [ __ ] up - mm-hmm
you know and it's just like oh those are
just like these weird comedic
experiences man probably like cuz like I
say you drunk guys you just get them
removed they know they're just like you
know they're being too much but it never
gets to a thing man
you ever had an altercation cuz I've had
I was attacked at the Comedy Store one
time no I do ran up through the crowd it
threw a chair at me really yeah I've
always wondered how I would react at
something like that like I had like a
guy like stand up once cuz I was making
fun of his wife but it was just like it
was he just stood up you know what I
mean it was like that's but good for him
cuz that's what I'm saying though so
obviously something was happening there
that that guy that happened to me at The
Improv - a guy was like he stood up he
was like you know you don't talk about
my was like oh now you guys want to be
upset about
mmm-hmm but like the wife was laughing
you know I mean I what the guy was just
like he was kind of joking her and there
was an I had never felt in any danger
whatsoever but I'm surprised that no
one's ever like the closest I number one
time I'm in the Comedy Store in the main
room and it's it's like a Saturday night
and I'm like half I'm five minutes into
my 15-minute set and this woman stands
up like in a like not in the all the way
back but like you like the middle back
and just scream stands up and screams
you are very offensive and I started
laughing so hard as I was just like I've
been killing for five minutes and like
of course like all of my jokes are very
offensive like I don't like what do you
want me to do and what did you think was
like we're not gonna drop the mic and
run backstage you know they figured me
out I don't my thing about it is like
what you say is like people don't I
think that people don't respect comedy
somebody these types of people and they
don't understand it like they they have
no idea that this is what this is about
like yeah I'm not saying comedy has to
be offensive but there's a spectrum that
it could get to an offensive place and
you have to know that it's not gonna
stay there especially on the show where
it's like these comics are doing 15
minutes each so like you don't like this
guy you gotta hug him just sit through
this the other guy will come on well
here's the thing if you're offended
you're not actually hurt in any way you
know I mean you might be offended and
then you like you get over it so more
quickly than anything else yeah like a
sneeze is more damaging to you then then
being offended that I don't care like
Willie Nelson had a great quote that I
love he goes if I hurt your feelings
that I'm sorry
but if I made you mad then [ __ ] you yeah
and I'm like that's what comedy is all
about yeah man I always feel like I want
to open up like you ever been to like
the restaurant dicks where it's like the
people are like the last resort yeah
Dick's last resort so I want to open up
an outrage restaurant where people are
allowed to be outraged
you know that's the whole thing with the
restaurant so like you know you would
have a comic and then the person is
allowed to go this is ridiculous and
then you know then a manager comes out
is everything okay and they're like well
he's saying something offensive I'm
gonna get him out of here
that's the whole theme of the restaurant
there could be outraged by everything
you know the waiter could come over and
go what are you two [ __ ] doing here
you know that they had to pretend to
beat the guy up in the back so then
people could get all that [ __ ] out yeah
I don't think that restaurant was evite
I just imagine like outrage I was gonna
ask you for money too
I just think the food would be terrible
it's so much time on this show yeah I
went to Dick's last resort I found out
about it when I was like like 14 and I
was like I want to be mayor dude like I
loved it so much I thought I was the
greatest no they did the funny thing
about it you'd be the guy where the
manager would be like can we talk in my
office yeah I understand that this is
dicks resort we're being mean to people
but there's a level that we would yeah
appreciate that you not go to too much
if you made a customer bleed like I
can't have that man what else are you
into besides comedy so we talk about
comedy so much so your sports guy
I'm sports guy um being from Pittsburgh
you kind of have to be oh you for
Pittsburgh yeah no that's big originally
so I'm a big you know and as I've gotten
older I've like I'm less passionate than
I was you know I used to be like crazy
and part of it is seeing your team win
you know yeah we I've seen them win a
couple Super Bowls I've seen the
Penguins win a couple cups that I I
enjoy it but I didn't make me mad I
don't like I don't play fantasy sports I
was asked you I was what if he's a
fantasy sports guy no never never and
like one of my best friend well at one
point was like the for most fantasy
football expert in the country and I
just like I root for the Steelers and I
can enjoy other people but I'm not gonna
ever be excited yeah that like that
Odell Beckham scored a touchdown
you know like against to be exactly I'm
not gonna put myself in that position
and it seems like [ __ ] waste of time
like I don't play video games either
like I understand them but I just like I
feel like I'm wasting my time that
honestly I don't watch much TV anymore I
read a lot I read a lot and I see movies
and even then movies now I'm like I'm
just I feel like I've just I feel and
movies just age I just feel like I've
seen it
you know something gotta knock me on my
ass to get me to
a critical thinker too I think that
that's a part of it you're very critical
thinker so like it's hard like I have
trouble at movies now - I the Bubblegum
stuff I can enjoy because it is what it
is like I'll go watch Avengers and I
know what I'm getting but like some of
these other movies you know like the the
Goldfinch whatever that one
I wouldn't saw that and I was like what
is happening here Goldfinch I mean did
you see that movie no the book is
amazing yes the books amazing but when I
read it I was like they're gonna try to
make this in a movie and it's gonna be
the most unwatchable [ __ ] ever it was
and it was yeah you know and I'm sitting
here like damn like you I want to enjoy
that though I love that visual like you
know I said let me see what this is
about but then when you're when you're a
comic you like you you just you find
yourself over analyzing things and if
the movie allows you to do that that
means it's not very good cuz I'm not
lost in it mmm-hmm you know I want to be
lost in it
one of my friends once said about comedy
and I think it applies to what we're
talking about now he was like I've seen
so much stand-up comedy at this point
that needs from to make me laugh you
either have to be like brilliant or my
friend you know I mean I can laugh
either one of those so now I feel like
that with movies and TV now that either
got to be like brilliant and TVs a
different thing because like peak TV
like I saw Sopranos I saw the wire
I said Deadwood stop breaking bad I some
Mad Men and I was like I'm done
people are like you guys see fleabag and
I'm like no I don't know I don't yeah
I'm not missing anything
or like a movies like if you seen
parasite yeah just just saw it's like
I'm like it that's what I wanted me up
you know what I mean like I don't want
to just sit there and be an hour no but
like I feel like TV shows are like
relationships and I can't get into
another relationship you know much of a
commitment much of a commitment
I had this rule DVR things so if four
episodes are in my DVR is that I haven't
watched I erased the show I just I just
don't even watch it because I go I'm not
interested in this I'm like I've got
seven episodes of Watchmen you know and
I like that [ __ ] what I decided to watch
the first one like five times I'm just
like I just can't do - it sounds weird
like I've watched I'm watching
and I every episode I go I don't know
what this is about I don't know who's
this character what are they doing why
are they there it's just one of these
weird shows that they're trying to like
I feel like HBO is trying you probably
weren't a game a felons person I was
huge Game of Thrones person really and
then the last season I hated every like
I hated him almost every second a little
episode I hate it okay how are you gonna
go six seasons to build up this thing
right and then because you got lazy you
go wow we're gonna finish this off in
eight or whatever it was yeah I what
and now that we can do it like should
you do it should you cuz you can yeah
doesn't mean you should like I was I and
what it did for me was like you know
what they did is like they ruined the
fantasy they ruined it because it's like
if you're playing fantasy football and
then somebody's going you know this
isn't real I don't want that person
around me cuz I'm like I love this
feeling so you had that Game of Thrones
me like oh let's see what the Lannisters
and you know and then they did this
season I was like what was that you
can't make that turn she made a turn in
like five minutes and she burned down
the whole city yeah hey I hated
everything about like I never minded me
was I was I was in Amsterdam I was on
tour this is the most recent time I've
been there before on vacation and you
know have you ever been Amsterdam no I
sure haven't there is a you know they've
got like the red-light district which
like the process heroes but they also
have this like famous building that the
second live sex shows and it's not the
only place that does it but in Amsterdam
is one like famous place and you go and
it's like on stage is like people
[ __ ] like to music and I bring my
opener it was a girl I'm Moe Welch very
funny and we're sitting in the back and
as soon as the curtains open and the
people start [ __ ] she leans into me
and she whispers I bet they're married
and I was like you just [ __ ] this
whole thing up for me why would you why
don't you just [ __ ] this or I can your
guarantee right and I let's let's leave
right now like I want to watch two
married people yeah it was like this is
like why did you do this yeah did you
know that this girl's damaged we have
family doesn't know where she has
let me make up a story in my head of why
they're doing this like I don't want to
know like you're just ruined it from
yeah that was a killer if that was it
the last season the Game of Thrones was
just like you you could just see you
could just you could just you could see
what they were doing you know and it was
it was unpleasant it was unpleasant like
you like the guy said that you know you
would like Queen that was like his whole
line they muster did they write that
like 75 times were they in the writers
room like somebody was like hey you know
what he should say that she's his queen
again you know you know and then this is
like it was like a drinking game it was
like let's just get it done yeah get it
over with and I hate that because I hate
that but anyways that's just an example
of a show we're like that was I must
watch almost like you know appointment
television but like these days now is
like if it's not I actually watch the
guilty pleasures like that more than i
watch the ones that everybody's telling
you to watch like I tried to watch
fleabag and I was like I'm out you know
anytime anytime Hollywood times start
going this oh you have to watch this
when I hear that that's a cue for me to
be like no thank you because that that
kind of pretentious [ __ ] I'm like
nah man that there's no to me the art is
lost in that when it's all about that
yeah you know I mean yeah so like I just
i watch like you know the Vampire
Diaries
those are kind of shows I just like lose
my you know just let me get on a couch
you just watch this nonsense for a
little while it's funny I went to a our
friend Morgan Murphy was like I'm she's
writing on Modern Family right now it's
the final season which is like who you
wanna come with me into a modern family
party and I was like what do you mean
she's like that one of the guys when the
cast members is hosting this party it's
near the comedy store I'll pick you up
in an uber after your show we'll go have
a drink
was it great and as I'm walking into
this party and it was like adds some
like hot like this Hollywood home that
like no one at the party owned it was
just like they've rented a home like oh
yeah this weird thing and like
bartenders everywhere I'm like it's not
a problem that I've never seen Modern
Family is it and I walk into this thing
and I'm meeting the actors and stuff and
they know don't know who I am that I go
you're I like your comedy then
and every single one of them cuz what do
you think of the show oh and I just
laughed and I've never seen an episode
and maybe like you're kidding cuz it and
they they weren't offended because
they're like we've won all these enemies
we've known for eight years like critics
love us like people people are watching
yeah yeah yeah and I was I was just like
they like you you have never seen an
episode of me do you think I've ever
watched ABC like do you think I ever do
you think I would like do you think
that's my jam like when people were
getting mad at Martin Scorsese on
Scorsese for for saying Marvel movies
aren't cinema and people who like my
favorite quote about some journalists
was like do you what do you expect from
Martin Scorsese just well expect them to
be like Oh Ant Man and the wasp
that's my [ __ ] like that's what I meant
to I I personally was offended by him
saying that because like the the
superhero stuff is are just a trope it's
just a thing that you use to tell a
story some of those people are really
great actors like like Robert Downey jr.
is fantastic he's a great actor so he
made it believable but like Scorsese
movies like he uses mob violence it's
the same [ __ ] usually mob violence in
every movie is like you could be like
that's not real movie either you could
say you know I understand what he was
saying I like people getting offended by
it like this guy's really [ __ ] old
and he's in the movies in a way that
like none of us are in just like but
what would it be if I came out I was
like you know what improv comedy is not
comedy oh you know I would agree with
you exactly but it's like why are you
like why even said like what's the point
of saying it I don't know who asked him
yeah or why he did it but like I saw
both sides and I see I see but I
certainly I certainly was not mad at him
for it or in any sort of disbelief so
you're not a kind of guy that would go
to watch an improv show
I just like I took an improv class when
I first started doing stand-up someone
was like you know it might help you know
they just they were like it's a tool
it's yeah it can be a tool and
especially if you're doing crowd work or
something or like you're getting heckled
like it is helpful I went took The
Groundlings class bro and I'm the
funniest guy in the class I mean it's
like me and a friend and I'm like it's
clear that I am the funniest one I'm not
the best improviser
but I'm the funniest guy in the class
and at the end you go in the hallway
after like eight weeks whatever you go
in the hallway they bring
one by one and the teachers like you're
gonna skip the next level yeah
or you're gonna take this level again or
you're just gonna go to the next level
but what I expected like they're gonna
be like hey [ __ ] Sunday company right
now so I walk in and she goes you're
gonna take this class again and I go
what are you talking about I go I'm the
funniest guy in the class and she goes
yes you are and that's important because
it's you can't teach funny she goes but
you're always Anthony and we're trying
to teach you to be like other like other
characters and stuff but you're always
Anthony when in whatever you do and I go
well you know what that's why I want to
be Anthony's [ __ ] hilarious
and I like got up and left and I like
and I never did improv again I was like
but I think if I'd stayed with it like
if you see B had been around maybe I
would have done that and they're they're
not at all about being big characters it
would have been a different thing maybe
I would be in movies and be acting more
because that had that skill but I just
thought you know what I'm just gonna
pour everything into stand-up well you
did a good job bro thank you I'm glad
I'm glad that you did you know what I
mean I think this is a good you know
you've been here a while this is a good
stopping point I don't I the fact that
you even here is like great like I if I
could I didn't flake out so I was like I
mean like I was I said this to Andrew
Santino I saw like that I actually saw
that moment I was like yes he's gonna
come but out but even to him I was like
did I want to come here
no no not am I happy hanging out and
being here did I have a good time yes
but it's like just getting me to do
anything
me to ask you to I had to it was like a
it was like a moment cuz I know you were
doing your show you know which which is
called used is it coming back
good talk yes yeah well obviously z'n to
I'd say it'll air probably around like
we haven't figured it out but spring
next year yeah so spring of next year
look for that on Comedy Central good
talk yeah so you were doing that I
thought the moment I I wait I like to
wait like I don't how to push it I can
wait I wait two years to be like hey
this is the moment I feel comfortable
enough we've been hanging out enough at
the store having conversations rounds
like I think is I can because I wanted
you to have feel completely okay with
being like I'm not gonna do that
mm-hmm you know and then I would you
would know that I would be okay with
that before it wouldn't be okay because
I put you in that position
like I gotta say no this guy I don't
really know I never I never feel bad
saying now still pocket I was just I
think I was like just doing a run of
them all right it functions right yeah
it was like I just did like three or
four in a row that people like felt come
it's like if you do an alt show yeah you
know then everyone starts reaching out
about an ultra that's like here at this
comedy store that I got there doing the
thing but if you do some movie theater
downtown you're gonna get a lot you're
gonna get hit by a lot of people to do
their show yes like if I set foot in the
belly room I would never hear the end of
it about if I use the [ __ ] bathroom
up there they would ever be asked me to
do every single show but you're there
it's not like they're asking you to go
down to a different location I know and
the belly room is the first stage I ever
performed on so I'd like meant a lot to
me and then one night I was just up
there eating [ __ ] knows why my doing
this
I just came from the main room where I
destroyed and now I've come on up here
to [ __ ] bomb like I didn't understand
why people I don't understand why people
go to the belly room if you're an
audience member and you're coming to the
Comedy Store and there's three rooms
yeah why the hell would you pick that
one yeah I know I know like with your
randomly coming that's why you have to
get people to come you have to have some
kind of event you know I mean you have
to have like I think they should do an
open mic in the belly room every day
therefore all those other comics Misha
just be going on every day from 7:00 to
10:00 or whatever it is but give people
you know but as an audience member if
you're like you have to walk by the o.r
to get to the belly room and then you
see the main room as you're walking
you're like well if you walk by this
like Rogen's on stage you're like okay
that looks good
yeah and then also you have to you have
to walk by the door the main room do you
go they really you like where my god
you're in the Attic yeah and no one
complains they're all just like the
beauty of the place but anyways I do
appreciate you coming on I'm gonna have
all of Anthony's information below where
you can find you know him well just on
Twitter out actually but you know I'll
have all your little whatever it is
right there and I do appreciate you
coming on this has been great
like I say thank you thank you for
having no Andrew stop it oh the last
thing about my podcast oh yes I read
right we got very smart what's his name
Jeselnik and Rosenthal vanity project
we call Jay our VP all the information
will be down there and that's another
episode of Riverwood girlfriend please
subscribe and share and do all that good
stuff
and I appreciate you guys hanging out
with me once again and I see you next
week
[Music]